es un compositor muy muy importante
importante
para nosotros entonces esta la musica clasica
entre comillas porque la música
orquesta nunca debe olvidar que es
tiene sus raíces en el folclore de
la musica de la gente en la musica
sonido popular y como a las 3 de la tarde para sonar
compositor importante y lo que empujamos
usted que es extremadamente importante en
mi vida para mi yo era percusionista y
así que tuve mucho
afinidad con la música americana
del sur que sea plata brasilera y
obviamente tambien la musica de america
centro y la primera grabación
profesional que hice como chef
de orquesta era un disco de la
musica de astor piazzolla todo el disco
es asi que me permitio entrar
sumergido en la música de este gran
compositor sino también de este gran
actuaciones de estos grandes artistas
y hay tanto de la paleta
emocional de su música que va desde
más de la mayor sutileza dulzura
sensualidad hasta la ira y
violencia al entrar en el bajo el
ombligo de lo que se llama tango
la milonga sigue siendo una norma imán
de la riqueza y por lo que era evidente para
para celebrar su música
aniversario
13 horas
[Música]